and hello everyone
welcome to this uh session
and welcome to this uh webinar
so my name is mohit mazumdar and
as many of you might be joining for the
first time so i have a phd in
computational biology and i have years
of experience working on various
biological problems doing research in
bioinformatics using computational tools
so today we will start by learning why
we are doing this first and then we will
learn about the various uh things
associated with the workshop and also
the schedule and uh the
experts who will be talking in this uh
in this
important workshop
that we'll be conducting from 26
december to 20th december
so um advances in sequencing and
computational biology have uh you know
drastically increased our capacity
to explore biology through this vast
amount of data so our understanding of
the world of biology is changing due to
many breakthroughs in biotechnology in
agriculture in infectious disease
research and also in other life science
research
so that is one of the key reason that we
design this workshop for beginners and
students who are starting their journey
with their specializations
specialization degrees that they are in
that you are enrolled in so students who
are doing b tech students who are doing
masters uh msc
mtech phd and people who are doing
research uh especially uh clinicians who
would want to learn about the uh
innovative industrial technologies
related to biological data analysis
so this program and this workshop
especially for anyone who would want to
have that who have this keen interest in
under and understanding that what is
going on so in today's world we are
learning from newspapers we are learning
from different sources about these
different uh breakthroughs that are
happening that that starts from the
development of vaccines to all the new
advancements that are coming for
diseases such as cancer and other
life-threatening diseases so and people
who are interested in doing that people
who have interest in learning about that
it is quite challenging to stay up to
the speed
and to learn that what is going on and
uh what are the ways we can contribute
what are the ways we can get into it and
start doing the same
so in this session uh we will learn
about topics and uh the curriculum that
will be covered in uh
that i'll be that we will be covering in
this workshop and that i will be cover
covering in this session along with the
resources that i said uh we have uh
resources that utilizes this innovative
omics logic bioinformatics training and
that will allow students to be a part of
this growing and rapidly evolving
community of researchers scientists
entrepreneurs and industry specialists
so this omixlogic short three-day
workshop registrations
will allow the participants to access
the self-learning course as you can see
in the screen there are some of the key
objectives that we have put together so
self learning courses and projects so
these are available uh on our propriety
portal learn o mix logic and platform uh
tbi info server so uh anyone who
registers will have access to all those
resources for 30 days from the day of
the registration
and a training on bio biological and
biomedical data analysis
using sequence and structural data and
then utilizing the big data
which is available on public
repositories so we will do that and over
the past few years uh i would like to
mention this that
our innovative technology that is being
utilized by multiple resources and
by creating pathways for students to
excel in their career has led to many
awards and recognition as you can see on
the screen so in india
we have collaborated and piloted our
training programs with
30 universities
for the last three years testing and
validating the project-based curriculum
to develop research ideas and research
projects and to support this
process
and to support this entire process from
training to be able to participate in
real and cutting-edge research
so this actually brings us to talk about
this opportunity this another
opportunity for students and faculty who
are interested in exploring the vast
multi-dimensional data and to gain skill
sets that are really
truly relevant to industry and also
academic research and that pertains to
you know deeper understanding of human
beings and all the other living beings
so the this omixlogic workshop is
designed for students and researchers
were eager to kick start their journey
to big data by understanding the
application from a biological from a
biologist prospective and solve the
challenge like an expert in
computational biology so that's what we
are going to expect from you after you
go through this training so this
especially this version of the workshop
is a special is a special opportunity
uh as we are glad to announce an
academic partnership with the premise
life
sciences and to tell you more about this
partnership
that will be helpful
for all of us going through this
experience because prima's life sciences
in india is a young dynamic and a
focused organization uh introducing
these game-changing niche technologies
such as genomics
uh this application in cell biology
biopharma to boost innovative research
and diagnostics in india
compared to the developing countries and
during this session the students from
the experts will learn about the cutting
edge and niche life science tools for
advanced for the advancements of indian
research and clinical diagnostics so it
will be a great opportunity in that
context so in this workshop and in order
to get you all a complete understanding
of
big data
from experts uh and we designed this
workshops with prima's life sciences
that will help
address the gaps uh so
that will be done via by doing a
pre-orientation workshop on 26 december
uh on ngs data generation and we will
cover next generation
machines um and some of the coolest
application in biomedical research so
let's learn about some of those topics
that will be covered covering uh in
in this pre-orientation session so this
workshop will commence on 26 december
which is on sunday and the first keynote
session will be about
illumina machines and data generation so
there will be a pre-orientation session
also before that for you to get started
and have all the login information and
all the access and all of that and then
we will start with the session the first
keynote session will be from 10 a.m to
11 a.m ist on 26 decem on 26 december
followed by that there will be another
session uh which will be about the
application in clinical uh in clinical
ngs and we will learn about important uh
terms and important things that are
going on in clinical engineers such as
oncology testing we will learn about
rare complex diseases we learn about
reproductive genetic diseases and
genetic health and microbial wellness
and whole genome sequencing so these are
really i mean topics that uh the
scientists are working on and using
their the insights from those are sort
of experiments and technology is helping
us to take critical decisions uh for uh
drug development on all of that so we
will go to that one by one in this
entire workshop and really excited to
learn more and more about it and also to
tell you more and more about it so after
learning about this clinical application
we will get to learn about the advanced
technologies that are emerging to
provide even deeper understanding of
each of the cells so in this last
session of the day
dr nitya ana nithyananda sharma senior
product manager uh singles and special
special genomics will talk about single
cell genomics and clinical paradigms so
you'll learn from data generation and
then clinical application and then you
will learn about the advanced
applications
so
followed by this uh the next part of the
workshop and the next part of the
workshop we will be learning about ngs
machines after learning about the ngs
machines and clinical application we
will be learning from the industry
experts uh about the biological data
analysis to learn about big data to
learn about databases to learn about
public repositories and to learn about
basics of data science and computational
biology so these are some of the things
that will be covered in the next two
days and uh
we will have experts for that so for the
next two days
along with me we will have experts from
our team to take you through these
different topics that i will go through
um in a while in some time but before i
do that
let's hear from our experts who are
present uh in this webinar uh so uh let
me invite dr raghavendran first who is
an expert mentor and a big data
specialist so